news daily from science mission I am
going to highlight some of the
scientific research that is making news
in the last 24 to 48 hours authors for
the first time in the journal Cell
reports show that stimulation of
astrocytes within the hypothalamus
reduces both basal and grayling evoked
food intake by modulating extracellular
levels of adenosine that act on
adenosine receptors inhibiting adenosine
receptors increased graylen induced food
intake next in the journal Nature
communications other show that peroxy
reduction for an endoplasmic reticulum
enzyme that metabolizes hydrogen
peroxide acts as a teen able regulator
of neurogenesis via its
compartmentalised tile oxidative
function peroxy roxina oxidizes two
cysteine residues on a protein called
gde-to and blocks its trafficking to the
plasma membrane and prevents neurogenic
function next in a recent paper
published in the Journal of Neuroscience
researchers followed the sequence of
pain impulses traveling from the Blaine
to the new spinal cord in mines and
showed that by removing the collection
of neurons called a1 that contain
dopamine chronic pain could be
selectively diminished by targeting
these neurons in mice with chronic pain
the researchers permanently reversed a
chronic pain State for more details
visit us at www.visaplace.com